does she suppose and strong your job
used to bring honor to the family do you
think you can do that in this video
we're gonna break down the biggest
moments and revelations from the new
trailer for mulan including mulan's new
family dynamic her new and even more
powerful enemy and her new surprising
character trait stick around to find out
just how much trouble Mulan's gotten
herself into this time
[Music]
right from the start of the new trailer
we were reminded of Milan's inspiration
to run off to war her ailing father but
unlike the Disney classic it's revealed
that Mulan is not her father's only
child she has a sister the added
responsibility of a sister likely makes
Mulan's decision to join the war all the
more important we wouldn't be surprised
to see this sister take on an important
role later on in the film we don't see a
lot of her grandmother or mother but
we're hoping the bond of the women in
the family will have more screen time
when Mulan is released next we see
Milan's father practicing with his sword
though he is unsteady move on
later picks up the same sword but makes
the vow of loyalty grace and truth
instead of devoting these values to
being a good wife as she must in the
animated movie she vows to devote them
to protecting her family by taking her
father's place in the war when Milan's
father realizes what she has done he
prays to the ancestors to protect her
though it has been confirmed that the
lovable ancestral dragon Mushu will
likely not be making an appearance in
the live-action film it is possible that
Milan's father's prayer means that
another ancestor may show up to lend a
hand
all the totems from the animated movie
offer a lot of choices for ancestral
guardians so we wonder who it could be
we also get a sneak peak of the soldiers
training camp and Commander toon the
camp seems larger and packed with more
soldiers than in the animation which has
likely a sign that the battles will be
much bigger this time around the
soldiers work in synchronised
determination leading us to believe that
they'll be even stronger in battle than
in the original Mulan and we can't
ignore the callback to the classic song
I'll make a man out of you as the
commander tells his troops that that's
exactly what he's gonna do
but a romantic relationship between
Mulan and the commander seems unlikely
because apparently Mulan will be finding
love within her own ranks in the
live-action remake while the commander
takes on the role of the mentor this
trailer also gives us a look at the
villain Shan Yu except it's not really
him in the live-action his name has been
changed to bori Khan
and he's not supposed to be the same
character but they're not fooling anyone
there is no mistaking his scarred face
and long dark hair or the hawk that we
see flying over the battlefield we see
him scaling walls with his army
promising us that he's bound to be just
as terrifying as Shane knew if not more
joining him is another villain that we
did not see in the animation the witch
Cheyenne Lang if her claws powers in
white painted face are to be of any
indication she is an even more fearsome
fighter as she helps bori con lay siege
to a village we see her strength any
battle she fights in is bound to be
fierce making her a good companion to
Bora Khan and a great and terrible
adversary from Mulan though we have yet
to find out more about her we briefly
see the witch go head-to-head with Mulan
herself and what is likely to be a
climactic battle
she tells Mulan that men will show her
no mercy for being a woman which is
powerful coming from a female who is
also a warrior this addition to the
story means that Mulan is no longer the
only female fighter which is a powerful
add-on to the original tale we can't
wait to see these powerful women
battling it out for the fate of China
even if they are on opposite sides one
of the most striking things from the
trailer is Mulan's long dark hair which
she frees from its bun as she enters a
battle there is no short hair for this
Mulan as she uses all of her power to
save China while also being strong and
confident in her womanhood and true to
Disney fashion she promises in the final
moments of the trailer that she will
bring honor to us all along with our I
will bring honor to us
[Music]
so what did you think of the trailer did
you spot anything we missed that's
getting you excited from Milan's 2020
release date let us know in the comments
and don't forget to Like and subscribe
to the things for more content see you
next time
you